hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome game from round one of the
aimches us rapid preliminaries it's
magnus carlsen versus wesley so and uh
like i said this is only a game from
round one so we're gonna dive straight
into it but i will mention it's the uh
ninth and the last event of the 1.6
million dollars meltwater champion
chester uh before the great final and
these are rapid games 15 minutes for all
moves with a 10 second increment
starting from move one so we're going to
discuss the tournament a little bit more
as we continue the coverage but this is
game one and it's already quite an
interesting one so magnus with the white
pieces uh opens with uh d4 uh we have
knight to f6 by wesley c4 uh that's not
a c4 we have c4 e6
bishop to f4 uh and now d5 and
interestingly here we have captures
knight captures attacking the bishop and
after bishop to g3 already as of move
five we have a completely new game uh so
let's see how wesley deals with this
novelty
we have c5 charging the center as why
not with e4 by magnus grabbing the
center attacking the knight and knight
to f6
we have knight to d2 already uh
a a clean pawn and while it's possible
to capture this uh wesley decides
against it wesley just continues
developing he plays knight to c6 and now
e5 attacking the knight here knight to
d7 and now knight g to f3 again asking
wesley are you maybe interested in a
pawn but wesley still uh has his dots
about it but now he captures the pawn he
plays c captures on d4
we have bishop to c4 by magnus and now
bishop to e7 we have castles and wesley
castles we have rooked the c1 now wesley
uh here uh
well being up a pawn but magnus is up in
development we have knight to c5 uh and
now uh a3 this knight could be a
nuisance here as this pawn could come to
d3 at some point it could be very well
defended and it's a pass pawn so you
have to do something about it the queen
could be coming to b6 uh challenging the
b dupont so here magnus plays a3 and he
prepares b4 to kick this knight away
from this excellent square uh wesley of
course stops this he plays a5 and not
knight to b3 offering a trade here and
while you could capture this uh and try
and keep your pawn uh captures captures
uh wesley again decides against this he
he plays b6 uh and now what uh wha what
does magnus play here he well he
reclaims his pawn he plays knight b
captures on b4 knight captures on d4 we
have knight captures and now bishop to
b7 so wesley does not want his extra
pawn but he has
developed his queen side very nicely the
bishop has been developed the queen will
now move and the rooks will occupy
perhaps the the open c and d file uh but
magnus says all right now my bishop pawn
and queen are eyeing that d6 square so
knights to b5 we're bringing this knight
to d6 and well that's going to be just
either a monster knight or black will
have to capture at some point and then
magnus will get a very nice pass pawn on
d6
so here you could trade queens but
wesley decides against it wesley plays
knight to e4 he wants to challenge the
dark square bishop here and now magnus
simply puts his knight on d6 a beautiful
square and like i said capturing here uh
although possible maybe gives magnus uh
too too great of a pass pawn
uh so here we have queen to b8 uh
not interested in capturing this knight
so queen to b8 and now comes queen to d4
by magnus a beautiful centralizing move
with the queen
although there is a there is a really
funky line with knight captures on f7
point is if rook captures you're going
to capture on e6 with the bishop you've
sacrificed a knight but you've grabbed
two pawns and you're gonna pick up the
rook as well the problem is if black
captures with the king and defends the
pawn then you have to go into something
like queen to g4 now attacking the d6
pawn
but after knight to c6 it seems like
everything is perfectly fine for black
but still could be very dangerous after
f4 f5 but it's uh
maybe something you don't do if you
don't have to do it so magnus continues
by simply uh developing centralizes his
queen and now
wesley plays also a very interesting
move and that's b5
now what's his idea behind this pawn
sacrifice uh well he wants uh uh white
to capture it now if you capture it with
the knight uh then well now you you no
longer have this beautifully posted
knight here and if rook to d8 uh we're
gonna play knight back to d6 and now
we're gonna capture but now we have an
extra piece here on the d file and after
everything gets traded off captures
captures uh you don't really have any
any worries here uh what's uh
uh really interesting is after uh b5 to
capture with the bishop and that's what
magnus does he plays bishop captures on
b5 and now uh you could go for rook to
d8 uh again it's a it's possible for
example after rook after d1 now we're
capturing d6 and after e captures we
capture on g3 h captures and then
unfortunately you don't have bishop
captures here by capturing this bishop
because white will play rook to c7 and
he will have just uh too strong of a
pig on the seventh rank uh so here you
would probably go bishop d5 attack this
bishop and now you would have a nice
double attack on this d6 pawn so it
could be played
but he decides against it after bishop
captures on b5 he decides to go for the
bishop first knight captures on g3 h
captures and now bishop to d5 so now
attacking the bishop and uh enjoying
this double attack on the knight on d6
we have bishop to c6 by magnus attacking
the rook here and the wesley of course
first eliminates the knight the bishop
captures on b6 now you can't capture the
rook if you capture the rook then wesley
will capture the pawn on e5 it's
defended by the queen and you will also
now lose this bishop here so black will
just be winning so after bishop captures
on d6 we have e captures on d6 and now
we have rook to a6
uh getting the rook out of harm's way we
have a capture on d5 captures on d5 and
now not recapturing but first rook
captures on d6 now the bishop cannot
move and the whistle is of course hoping
to just recapture here with with the
pawn uh magnus plays rook to c5 so now
you can't really uh keep your pawn uh
because uh well your a5 pawn is hanging
and if you try something like rook here
still we're just gonna capture on a5 and
after rook capture sunday five rook
captures sorry rook captures on d5 rogue
captures we're gonna play queen to c3
and we're gonna enjoy two connected pass
pawns on the queen side so of course
wesley is not interested in playing
against this so after rook the c5 we
have rook captures on d5 and now rook
captures we have e captures on d5 and
now queen captures on the e5 queen
captures on b2 and queen captures on a5
so after all is said and done we have a
queen and the rook against the queen and
a rook both players three pawns on the
king side but the magnus has an extra
pass spawn on the queen side it's an
outside pass pawn so of course uh it's a
very dangerous by its nature but he has
double points on the king side so maybe
something for wesley to to utilize later
on uh we have g6 you want to bring your
rook into the game so we want to create
a some reading square for your king and
now queen to be four by magnus he offers
a queen trade and offers to go straight
into rook and pawn in game and wesley
declines this we have queen to f6 and
now of course magnus starts pushing his
past pawn with a4 and rook to c8 now
rook to a8 also possible wesley decides
to go rook to c8 we have a5 by magnus
and now h5 uh we have queen to a4
putting a queen behind the pass pawn now
you want to start pushing it and now
rook to c6 so now wesley's queen and
rook are guarding the a6 square so it's
going to be very hard for magnus to
advance this pawn even further so what
do you do queen to a1 again magnus
offers a
queen trait and you could go for this
but after captures and captures the
problem is you have to immediately block
the spawn with rook to a6 and then you
have a really passive rook white has a
well a much more active rook and you're
just gonna start by bringing your king
into the game of course black will have
to either go with the king to the queen
side to help out with this spawn uh
which will not be possible because then
the white king will just gobble up all
of the queen side pawns so uh you would
have to
you know choose
between the lesser evil here so instead
wesley goes king to g7 he says all right
let's trade queens but then my king will
be a much more active king so here rook
to b1 first magnus brings the rook into
the game and now queen captures an a1
now wesley traits as he won a temple
with king to g7 so rook captures on a1
now again magnus ready to start pushing
his past a pawn and of course rook to a6
so we basically get the same idea that
we discussed only wesley now has uh well
he he saved the temple with his king so
f3 magnus now ready to start bringing
his king into the game and we have uh
king to f6 king to f2 we have king to e5
and now king the e3 uh we have king to
d5 wesley now has to play something but
you don't really want to play anything
you uh really prefer to have your king
opposite the white king but you have to
play something so king f4 and now f6
preventing the white king from going any
further we have g4 by magnus he says i
have a double g pawn so why not just uh
trade one of them uh we have captures
captures and now king to e5 wesley says
thou shall not pass but magnus says nope
that's that's really not a problem uh he
plays f4 chases away wesley's king and
now king to e6
uh if you if you try and remain on the e
file for example with king to e4 uh we
can always chase it away with a move
like rook to a rook to e1 rook to a4
and so on so here magnus wastes a move
and he does so very nicely he plays rook
to a2 and now the problem is uh if you
move the rook we're just going to
continue pushing our pawn if you make
any opponent advance it only favors
white and well you basically you can
only move your king and this is what
wesley does
we have rook to east akink to a7 and now
king to f3 uh we have king to d6 now
comes king to e4 and king to e6 wesley
again gains opposition uh but magnus
says i can always waste a move with rook
to a1 whereas you can't really waste any
moves so king to d6 and only now after
the king moved we have f5 by magnus and
now the problem is wesley can't really
play g5 uh because we can always move
around with our king king f3 and if king
if king e5 going after the pawn we play
king g4 we defend it if king the e4
trying to remain here attacking this f5
pawn we simply chase the king away
rookie one check king d5 and now rook to
e6 and this is not uh
game over for for black uh if you trade
then white has his uh past a pawn which
is of course completely winning and if
you trade here then we capture on f6 we
capture on g5 and then we have two
connected pass pawns on the king side uh
which is of course winning for magnus so
instead after f5 wesley trades we have
captures captures and now king the e7 uh
continuing defending this f6 pawn king
to g6 and now king to e6 keeping the
opposition but now rook to e1 with check
uh we have king to d7 and now okay now
the rook is defending the f6 pawn but
now just g4 so what do you play here uh
if you capture an a5 that's a problem
captures captures and it's basically the
same endgame this is completely winning
the black king cannot help out the rook
is completely controlling the e file and
this is straight out winning so after g4
we have king to d8 by wesley now comes
king to f7 now after this pawn falls and
it will the king will control these
three crucial squares for this pawn to
be promoted to a queen
and here for example if king to d7 we're
just gonna play rookie seven check now
if you go here we deliver check pick up
the rook so you'd have to go up the
board and only then we play rookie six
and now black has nothing better but we
get pretty much the same end game we're
just gonna escort our pawn up the board
and that's it so after king to f7 we
have rook to d6 wesley is now forced to
move the rook and now uh comes a very
interesting move and that is rook to e4
rook to e4 with the idea of defending
the g4 pawn if you just tried rook to f1
going after the f6 pawn then wesley has
this rook d4 and now it's uh well it's
not as clean as it should be so after
rook the d6 like i said rook to e4 and
now there's really no good move here now
you are playing uh rook to f4 and that's
that's all there is we have rook to c6
wesley wastes a move but now rook to d4
check king to c8 uh moving the king
further away from from the past pawn and
now rook to f4 and he was in this
position on move 55 that wesley so
resigned the game and a very nice
victory for magnus carlsen in round one
of the
first round of this of this very nice
event uh here again you resign it's
pretty much the same thing you have to
make a move there really are no good
moves if you deliver a check we pick up
the pawn with the king then we escort
our pawn of the board and if you go
after this pawn not much different we
capture with the rook and after rook
captures on a5 yes you are guarding g5
but simply rook f5 and that's it once we
deliver one check the king will move
king to f8 and now we just escort our
pawn up the board and that's it
so a very nice game by magnus and very
nice surprise for wesley uh creating a
new game already as of move five uh
we'll continue covering this tournament
if you have any favorites of your own do
use hashtag suggestion and i will go
through them and hopefully cover them uh
so that's the game hope you guys enjoyed
it i would like to thank tom daralo and
niraj and kerala alain
david kimura and vlad ularu for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it as usual you
can check to all my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of this
very nice event checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day